[music playing]
John, Jeff, you
gentlemen are entering
the final round of this
three-round competition.
Now we're sending
you back to your home
forge to recreate this
iconic weapon from history.
That weapon is the
messer and by-knife.
It going to be a challenge.
Good luck, bladesmiths.
We will see you in four days.
[inaudible]
So I'm back at my
home forge, and I'm
really excited about that.
But I get four days to make
two blades, and that's insane.
I don't have time
to do one at a time.
This is going to be
two irons in the fire
and swapping them in and out.
You know, I'd much rather
be able to concentrate
on one thing, but it's
"Forged in Fire," baby.
Got the blades all forged out.
One of the parameters
for the sword
is that it has to have a fuller.
Putting these fullers
in is probably
the most nerve-racking part.
You can get them too deep.
You can get them off-centered.
Screwing these fullers
up could mean day
one is starting over tomorrow.
Yes, sir, that'll work.
I'm finally home.
I'm ready to roll.
Check it once.
Check it twice.
Check it 10 times.
Today, I want to start
with my by-knife,
so I know how much time
I have to work with
to make that long messer.
Blade's got to be
between here and here.
This homie don't
mess up his lengths.
I've managed to forge
out the by-knife.
Things are going a
lot quicker than I
ever expect they would be.
I'm liking it.
So, I'm going to start
attacking the long messer.
I've never done anything
quite that size.
Come here, you big monster.
It's scaring the
bejeebers out of me.
Still got my fingers
crossed that I've got
the length I want.
I'm ready to quench.
Two quenches, twice the
work, twice the worry.
Yes, sir.
The messer sword is
up to temperature,
and it's time to quench.
Here comes the real test.
Please be hard.
Yes.
Hell, yes.
This is my baby now.
[laughs]
So let me take care of it.
Today, I need to get
the messer heat treated.
If it cracks, I don't know that
I'm going to have enough time
to make another one.
Well, that's 18 hours
of busting my butt.
It comes up to this.
Right now, the only plan
B I can think of is cry.
[rock music]
[sighs]
That's called a sigh of relief.
[laughs]
This son of a gun is straight.
Oh, that worked great.
I'm starting day
four, and I'm a lot more
tired than I was at day one.
I'm getting the parts
together for the messer sword.
I'm doing the final
fit and grind on them.
[laughs]
Duel weld.
That thing just makes
you feel like a bad ass
when you're holding it.
I mean, I have to chop
something with it.
So to test my messer
sword, I do an antler chop.
Antler is some tough stuff,
and if it survives it,
it should survive anything.
Hopefully it doesn't break.
I'm getting what I want.
I'm still trying to get it a
little sharper for slicing,
but for chopping, man,
it's freaking awesome.
All right,
bladesmiths, this is
the pig carcass slice and dice.
I will take your weapon
and deliver killing
blows on this pig carcass.
John, you're up first.
You ready for this?
Let's make some bacon, bud.
This is not an
easy test to pass.
This is where I find out, did
I make a sword or a couple
pieces of scrap metal?
[music playing]
Oh, yeah.
Yes.
All right, John.
Your messer is sharp.
It's a little bit forward-heavy,
but the weight lends
itself to chop the pig in half.
Now, your by-knife, razor sharp.
Those cuts alone were cutting
deeply with every move.
And overall, sir, it will kill.
Oh, yes.
All right, Jeff.
Your turn.
You ready?
Yes, sir.
Let's do this.
[music playing]
[laughter]
All right, Jeff.
Your messer, beautiful balance.
It's not forward-heavy.
It actually is
something I can wield.
Forward, same balance
on the recovery
when I'm pulling back to cut.
Now, your by-knife.
The edge is razor sharp
with every cut and stab
that it does.
Overall, sir, your
weapons, they will kill.
Thanks, sir.
All right, gentlemen.
Now, to test the strength and
durability of your blades,
I'll be chopping
into our log here.
Now remember, this is not
about what your messers are
going to do that log,
but what that log
might do to your messers.
And then I'm going to
take your by-knives,
and we're going to do a tip
test by driving that tip
of your blade into that log.
All right, John you're up.
You ready?
Do your worst.
OK.
[music playing]
All right, John, well, let's
start with your messer.
Your edge is still sharp.
Blade's still straight and true.
Your blade's got a
lot of weight to it.
Your handle is a
little confusing
when you're swinging this.
Having that bead right there,
my hand kind of wants to go
all the way up to the guard.
And having this, the
well, further back sort of
pushes my hand a little bit back
behind where I'd like it to be.
As far as your by-knife
goes, not a mark on it.
Really well done.
Thank you, sir.
All right, Jeff.
Your turn.
You ready?
Yes, sir.
OK.
[music playing]
All right, let's start
with your messer.
What I really like
about this blade
is the way you balanced it.
It puts all that weight
right back in my hand
where I want it.
Your knife, it's a
really pretty piece.
It's very comfortable
in the hand, but just
a little brittle on the tip.
But they are both
beautiful pieces.
Nicely done.
Thanks, sir.
All right, bladesmiths,
the rope slice surprise.
Now, unlike the
strength test, this
is all about what your edge will
do to different materials we
have out here.
John, you're up first.
You ready for this?
Please do, sir.
Let's do this.
[music playing]
All right, John.
During the first couple, your
by-knife, it's a light knife.
It didn't cut all
the way through.
It started to unravel.
And of course, your
messer finished that off.
On these tubes, this cut
cleanly all the way through.
Your weapons, sir, will cut.
Thank you.
All right, Jeff.
It's your turn.
You ready, sir?
Yes, sir.
[music playing]
All right, Jeff.
First up your by-knife.
Despite the fact that
just the tip broke off,
the edge is razor sharp.
With one cut, it cut
cleanly through the rope.
Your messer, once
again, the balance
just feels so good in the hand.
It's such an easy weapon
to wield and slice.
Overall, sir, your
weapons will cut.
Thank you, sir.
They're going
to be judging both
of these weapons, not just one.
The knife broke, but the sword
performed above and beyond.
It's anybody's game, I think.
Bladesmiths, the judges'
deliberation is complete.
They've made their
final decision.
Our new "Forged in
Fire" Champion is Jeff.
Congratulations.
You're the new "Forged
in Fire" Champion.
John, unfortunately, your
blades did not make the cut.
John, while Jeff's
by-knife's tip broke
on the strength
test, it outperformed
yours on the sharpness test.
The combination of the
balance, the forward weight,
and your handle design,
well, that's the reason
we're sending you home.
John, please
surrender your blades.
[music playing]
Somebody has to win.
And I wish it
could have been me.
But I honestly feel the judges
made the right decision.
Jeff's messer was a work of
art, and he deserved to win.
What I loved about
this is that it
stretched me far beyond
what I thought I could do,
and I did it.
Jeff, congratulations.
You're the new "Forged
in Fire" Champion.
And that's a title that comes
with a check for $10,000.
How do you feel right now?
[laughs]
Validated.
Sir, please, present
your blades to the judges.
I'm happy.
I can't even describe
my emotions right now.
"Forged in Fire" Champion, baby,
bringing it back to Kentucky.
Hell yeah!
Yes!
[music playing]